President Biden is the oldest president
in U.S history why does White House
staff treat him like a baby no one
treats the president of the United
States the commander-in-chief like a
baby so there's this book that says
that's ridiculous
Corrine Jean-Pierre trying to defend the
big baby in the White House concerns are
growing over Joe Biden's age after a
damning new book revealed how the
president constantly feels tired and
can't hold an event before 10 A.M
Americans agree that Joe Biden should be
headed for retirement a whopping 73
percent of Voters say yes President
Biden is too old to run but your concern
is just all a big joke to the big guy
[Laughter]
[Applause]
I tell you what
someone said you know that body is
getting old man I'll tell you what well
guess what guess what okay you know the
only thing that comes today is a little
bit of wisdom hi Bob
I've been doing this Lauren anybody and
I guess what I'm going to continue to do
with your help
and like a true baby he needs his rest
President Biden getting called out for
being on vacation all the time and
especially during natural disasters like
the one we saw in Maui but little did
you know he wasn't actually on break
I'll let Joe explain that one
I'm here to make it secure so I have no
place to go when I come to Delaware
except here right now I'm only here for
one day no I'm not homeless I just have
one home I have a beautiful home but I'm
down here for the day because I can't go
home Biden's got other problems despite
being old and apparently homeless that
same poll has him tied with former
president Trump in a hypothetical
matchup and the media is panicking
it is kind of shocking in a way that
despite all of the baggage that Donald
Trump carries he's tied with Joe Biden
right now I've never seen anything like
this with Donald Trump I mean what
doesn't kill you make you stronger I
mean being convict I mean being indicted
that's making him stronger raising 10
million dollars using an ugly mug shot
after the mug shot and for criminal
indictments you would think President
Biden would have a significant Advantage
but apparently not
Greg I do want to clarify to the
audience that we're not calling Joe
Biden a baby he called himself a baby
we're just repeating the things we heard
we're outfitting though that this
President is homeless think about it
think about it the hood ornament of this
country where they where the the
homeless today are essentially our
national bird everybody's got them can't
do anything about it be happy he's on
vacation imagine him when he's not on
vacation and I like how they were
shocked they were shocked that Trump is
still able to be tied with Biden no they
should be shocked that Biden is able to
be tied with Trump sure you can keep
throwing January 6 out there but all in
all Trump is still coaching he's still a
human being he still can use his brain
what you have there is not workable and
that's not even the reason for concern
by by feeling about this I was away for
a week so I've been thinking about this
a lot go ahead I've gained some weight I
don't feel comfortable in my pants
but Biden is barely a figurehead and
what scares me when I was at home was
nobody seems to care that nothing is
getting done so it's not about Joe it's
about the party and politics itself that
people aren't doing a thing
and they aren't even helping to do it so
if you ask the Democrats what do you
want well we want to have Criminal
Justice Reform we want to have a a safe
effective border where everybody can
come and have a chance at the American
dream but then you ask them for the
process and there is none because they
don't have one right so the whole thing
is a sham we're sitting I mean I'm
waiting for and I know that America is
it's summertime it's not going to happen
for another year
you if you've got to wake up and see
that we've got some massive problems the
three obvious ones are education
immigration and crime we have a
president who's a half wit parties who
are involved in dueling indictments and
nobody is doing a thing about the
problems that you see every day
meanwhile you have a Democratic party
that calls everybody racists and they're
gonna double down on the old white guy
right if Biden were a republican the
Democrats in the media would say it's a
party of old white men well what do you
have here you have a party of radicals
that are propping up an old white man to
get back into the White House that's
worse I think your pants fit just fine I
feel sloppy and sweaty well you look
great I would thank you Dana
Stephanopoulos is blind to not be able
to see the the base would rally behind
this president after these indictments
does he even cover politics well I do
think that a lot of them and you saw it
in the other I don't know the other
Anchor's name the blonde woman who said
you know she thought that the
indictments would do something but I
guess not but they were definitely
counting on that that's why you got all
of them and that's not working by
Dynamics as a theme isn't working you
also in that same poll that Greg and you
mentioned by an eight point margin more
voters said Trump has a vision for the
future and elections are about the
future and there's also people saying
that they want change last week the poll
said 77 percent of Americans think he's
too old this week it's 73 so I'm pretty
sure that's not an outlier this is just
a consensus and if it weren't a visual
medium today or like it weren't the
Modern Age Joe Biden might be able to
run if it was like 1884 right and like
nobody could see when he was 12. the
White House is trying to tell you that
you're not seeing the things that you're
seeing and there's it's nothing that the
right is saying about Joe Biden people
are seeing it with their own eyes the
econ I would just add on those three
things I totally agree with you but the
economy the numbers for Biden on the
economy are really bad and I don't talk
to Karl Rove this morning on the show
and he said he doesn't see them pivoting
I don't see how they can right now all
they're doing is telling you that you
feel wrong about the economy but young
people older people everybody's feeling
squeezed nothing's getting done we
talked to a lot of Mayors had one on
today from Casper Wyoming Mayor Bruce
Nell great guy I said why is he coming
on oh guess what they have a homeless
crisis in Casper Wyoming and that winter
is going to be very cold and none of
these people feel like they're getting
the support that they need including my
last comment Blue State Governors where
is the pressure coming on the White
House now it's not from Greg Abbott they
blew him off the governor of Texas they
don't care about the board down there
but if the blue State Governor starts
saying we demand something from the
White House they might start to have to
listen Dana do you think Casper will
become a ghost town
Greg you've been off for too long so the
president seems to be pivoting from the
age issue and turning it into a wisdom
play I'm laughing because Joe Biden and
wisdom don't belong in the same sentence
together is he going to be able to pull
that off
I don't know we have to wait for
election day this country is so utterly
polarized and that's how you end up with
43.43 right those are Democrats versus
Republicans and then you see where
Independence fall and that's who gets
the White House that's how this goes
um I have been consistent on this I
don't think you should laugh off the age
concern it is for I have I know a lot of
Genuine Joe Biden supporters people who
have worked with him for decades Etc
very happy with the list of
accomplishments and there are a lot of
them like last week the vine
Administration got it that we're now
going to start negotiating 10 drugs with
Medicare pricing that's something that
Republicans and Democrats have been
promising to do he actually got that
done he's lowering the cost of drugs for
seniors in this country that's a real
thing you can run on but if people are
consumed with this and if you're kind of
saying oh well you know it's no big deal
then they're going to get pissed off
about it does that mean they're going to
vote for the other guy I don't think so
I mean the other guy is so polarizing I
mean 51 of the new CNN poll says the
January 36 charges are just flat out
disqualifying not a conviction just the
charges in the first place but it's
going to be very close and I think that
Democrats are stronger when we're
worried and when we're concerned and
trying to put the Coalition together he
has a softness with latino voters that's
been consistent running behind where
Hillary was and where Obama was behind
uh White voters who didn't go to college
not supporting him as strongly as they
did I understand Trump still won them
but he got a higher proportion and then
you have a concern over what's going on
with black men in this country not
because he's going to win the black vote
that is an absurdity about Trump but if
you lose one or two percent
that could be the whole ball game so
Democrats keep wetting your pants we got
an election but at this time when Obama
was running for re-election Romney was
up and look how that turned I mean we're
14 months out okay
Greg go back to Vacation the uh the
bottom line is money you have 2 000 less
dollars in your pocket under Joe Biden
than you had under Donald Trump and and
no
you know
publicity stun is going to be able to
change that look the most powerful
discontent in on every American's mind
right now is money inflation and where
they are and they can talk about
Dynamics until the cows come home but
the truth is inflation is still high
people don't have the ability now I hear
it's the worst housing market in in
decades right now to buy a house but you
know in addition to all that the thing
that you know Jessica talks about a
country that is so polarized and it is
polarized so you have to ask yourself
how is it that 73 of Americans can agree
on one thing one thing they can agree on
and that is that Joe Biden is too old to
run for reelection and there was a great
article in the Wall Street Journal today
that talked about Joe Biden's iron grip
on the party and they compare it to
omerta which is what the the mob does so
if someone commits a crime in the mob
everybody's behind them everybody's got
out a closed mouth till they go till
they die and the the questions that were
raised in this article are incredible
these stupendously incompetent pull out
from Afghanistan occurred early in
Biden's term it would have destroyed any
other presidency they talk about all of
the things that he's done improperly and
that would have destroyed any president
but the Democrats so hate Donald Trump
their their hatred of him outweighs
their love for this country so they're
willing to live with all of this stuff
and let me just say another thing you
know Joe Biden comes out and he has the
unmitigated Gall to say that Donald
Trump didn't build anything and so what
I did was I went in and started looking
at all the things that Donald Trump did
and built before he became president and
whether it's in the biggest let me just
finish whether it's in the beginning of
his career or right until he ran for
president it is it is unparalleled what
he did from Mumbai to Dubai Etc
Etc from Scotland and then when he was
in the white house he talked about you
want to talk about what he built he
rebuilt the economy you talk about one
or two percent of African Americans they
got jobs more than they've ever had
under any other president let me finish
and the Democrats fought him every step
of the way to Build That Wall he had to
go to the Supreme Court to get the wall
built and if he there's one thing he
really needs to be credited with
building a rebuilding and that is the
military just the black unemployment
rate on the Hispanic unemployment rate
is the lowest it has ever been and
that's under President Joe Biden not
Donald Trump you know the only thing Joe
Biden built was a tax shelter Jessica
yeah he never signed the dog
the most shocking footage yet of
democrat City violence hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else